hello everyone thanks for coming I'll be
presenting today putting tons of love to
mothers into production tensorflow team
released this year's tensorflow to into
production production it is no longer
far it is no longer beta it is no longer
the least candidate it is production
ready and today I will be mainly talking
about tons of flow to updates it
happened on the transfer flow one and
how do we deploy these models into the
production I was searching in image on
how to deploy transform others into
production
I find this image very absurd where it's
basically suggested you have a phone you
click on ITF transfer logo and then it
just deploys the model to the production
I wish most of the things are that easy
maybe maybe this will take another 10-15
years to go from what we have right now
to deploying the transfer flow logo and
then deploys this into the production a
little bit about me I work at Walmart I
have been working in Walmart for about
more than a little bit more than three
years now I was part of the jet camp I
used to do recommendations and query
suggestions there my team then after the
acquisition of jet come to Walmart
my team did visual search for hay needle
a needle is another company that is part
of Walmart that does home and furniture
products and then we are more and more
focusing on the textual search in
Walmart calm as well as store search we
are hiring this year played aggressively
we are going to hire 10 15 more software
engineers or machine learning engineers
if you are interested in an open
position either in Sunnyvale and San
Francisco or Hoboken New Jersey office
please shoot me an email and I will be
sharing the presentation as well as the
notebooks that I will be going through
in my Twitter account
there before the talk I kind of want to
set expectations where I won't be
talking a lot about building models I
won't be talking a lot about training
models I won't be talking about a lot of
data processing and validation the idea
is not so much about me talking about
these concepts but rather I want to
spend a little bit more time on what
goes after you train the model what goes
into after you built the model I will be
showing the building piece as well as
the training piece some of the examples
for transfer all data sets however most
of my time is going to spend on what
goes next after you have the model after
you train the model the training model
is already solve problem anyways so wide
even kind of talked about right you had
this machine learning system it is a
pile of linear algebra you put some data
if it doesn't work you put more data and
steal the pile and then try to see if
the results look good so the the talk
has the transfer flow name itself and
this talk is mainly about tensor flow
and transfer has a number of advantages
over other libraries Google defines and
tenth open source platform for machine
learning this is more like an
aspirational description then attack
then it actually what it is it is not
really a platform it is a machine
learning library and the key piece of it
is actually it tries to be the entrant
machine learning platform most of the
libraries that you have at out there is
focusing on either the training piece of
it or the building part of the machine
learning life cycle where they don't
necessarily focus on the model
deployment how the model is drifting in
production what is the prediction
latency and a bunch of other stuff that
actually makes model
to provide customer value in a real
production setting and this might be
fine for the scenarios where you have a
CSV file where you have a database and
then you run an offline analysis and
then produce predictions and then you
output those predictions into yet
another CSV or a sequel table this
workload might be perfectly fine in
search we cannot really afford this
because the customer is very contextual
and all of the queries are in real time
and we need to serve real customer
requests in in a production in a real
time scenario and transfer is great for
this type of production settings because
it supports a number of things out of
the box I will spend a little bit of
time for each snip for each sections in
here not everything is as important as
you know some of the other things but
overall it kind of provides all of the
advantages of that library over all of
the other available alternatives out
there
the first one is lazy evaluation right
now they also support eager execution
with the transfer flow to this
evaluation provides you a way to define
your computation beforehand and then
transfer all will understand what the
execution fully execution entails what
does it mean is you now specify a number
of operations that you want to operate
on top of the data and then when
transfer flow builds the graph intent
then it can execute and it can optimize
that graph quite a bit while you may
want to get benefit from it lazy
evaluation aspect the second we are
going to talk transfer model serving
quite a bit they actually have a
separate component it is full production
ready to make the serving layer of the
model much easier most of the machine
learning libraries don't provide this
type of mechanism to make the model
deployment easier available
production-ready models as
since Google supports obviously want
this community to be adapted because of
research reasons but also because I
think their GCP strategy they are also
making a number of models available for
anyone to download and I want to use in
a commercial setting in a non-commercial
setting it tells a number of models that
are really really performing well it is
also a lot of community support and the
tensorflow itself was released in
November 2000 19 so 2015 sorry it has
been more than four years and I think it
is one of the mostly white adopted deep
learning library comparing to for
example python which is much newer it is
open source I'm not going to spend any
time on this this conference could ton
of emphasis on the open source already
and support is another excellent
component that it provides out of the
box where you can do all of your
analysis in a much better integrated
environment with the tensorflow it also
supports distributed training support so
if you are kind of provisioning a number
of machines in GCP then you will be able
to use these distributed machines with
fully natively supported from tons of
loft if you have the GPUs in those
machines it can also utilize this GPUs
currently they also support TPU standard
processing units which is available in
Google cloud platform GCP to make the
computation in a shorter time frame
although the GPU and TP machines are
always so much more expensive than the
CPUs and as I mentioned it is pretty
widely adopted and the adoption piece is
the stuff is not very important but if
you are facing a question if you are
facing a problem when you ask when you
basically get that error message and
then type in in Google and then will be
able to find the results or the
solutions in Stack Overflow or ended up
it is very important for engineering
productivity so I mentioned these all of
the good stuff that it provides but
why would anyone actually not use
transit floss the problem it has also
its own problems it is debugging is not
very easy the stack trace as well as the
internal error messaging are not very
well implemented especially in terms of
flow one it needed a lot of boilerplate
code to be able to just glue a number of
pieces that are very important together
interfaces are not very obvious to
figure out this always I compared with
the scikit-learn
in scikit-learn you don't need to know
the class name you know which function
to call which function to use no matter
what the model was because the all of
the models share a very common interface
so you don't have to think a lot about
what to call even on the object level
where in the transfer flow there are
many ways to do things and some of the
interfaces are not very obvious to
figure out some of them are using
interesting names some of them are just
not very well supported this place also
ended the second piece of it it is it
was very cluttered library in the
transfer flow one they created a new sub
module which was the country and country
back Chile get a lot more contribution
from community that was great but then
nobody really supported maintain that
piece and then over time the maintenance
become really hard and then people are
using different types of sub modules to
do the same exact thing and it became
really hard to maintain it also didn't
have dynamic graph support in terms of
flow one now they support dynamic graph
support and all of the errors problems
that I mentioned that was actually
specific to transfer flow one it is now
a bit better
for example interfaces are so much
better because they adapted most of most
of the places charrisse's interface they
deprecated removed a number of modules
in terms of flow to basically they are
not they are basically saying that we
are no longer supporting this
boilerplate code is very minimal enough
it is not in the same level as pay torch
PI torch I think is one of the you know
best libraries did get actually write a
no boilerplate code you just write code
that actually matters however a transfer
is also going there and they provided
transfer all data sets this is not so
much about specific to tensorflow to
however and now it is much more
maintainable and supported much more
robustly by the tensorflow team and now
turns the flow hub which you can
consider guitar for the transfer flow
models is natively integrated into a
transfer floor to which I will explain
what it means a little bit later as I
mentioned the disadvantages are a little
bit less enough overall if you look at
kind of the tensor flow to echo system
you can consider there are two main
components training and deployment and
then you have an interface between
training and deployment for civilization
for model repository on the deployment
piece it is basically producing these
predictions to the customers on the
training piece it is the most commonly
you know understood data science flow
where you have a number of data and then
you build your model you execute compute
that model and then through analysis you
iterate on top of this when you think
you have a good model
you kind of serialized that and then
after that it is part of kind of the
deployment piece in Walmart generally
this is done also is two separate teams
so it is very important to have a common
interface where the engineering focus
teams are more interested in this piece
and the data science teams can do
implement this piece and in software
engineering right if you kind of try to
make a comparison software engineering
is very similar kind of CRC the pipeline
piece where you do your code changes in
here you have got your unit test
regression test you after you get
your peer-reviewed did create an
artifact early it is pushed into an
artifact early repo or you know some
other mechanism and then now the DevOps
flow will start where you put your art
factory and enough let's create a
deployment strategy to be able to deploy
that code change obviously machine
learning is not as mature as a software
engineering so they're I think trying to
borrow of some of the these ideas to be
able to implement and especially the
state model is making a lot of progress
and with the tensorflow to now it is
much more elevated de facto civilized
civilization format for training as well
as the deployment and now we can
actually use the same exact state model
to be able to download tensorflow of hot
models which basically works exactly how
we train the model so it is no longer
any different there is no any difference
between you pull a model from transit
flow hub and then you train a model on
your own machine and then you want to
deploy those two models as long as the
civilization format in state model it
works exactly the same way and in order
to kind of even improve the situation if
you want to reuse some of the tensorflow
hub components you can also see light
this relies into the state model you can
retrain the same model and then push to
the customer on the deployment piece so
this works now very seamlessly on the on
the set model piece which we are going
to talk a little more on the state model
and the other things is TPU is only
available right now as far as I know in
GCP gpo
is available in if you want to deploy
AWS or as your based on your you know
cloud provider that works the same way I
just had experience on the Nvidia side
but I believe all of the other graphic
drivers companies would also work the
same way and the model design now with
this cast estimator so it is much better
and the chief data provides a way to
physically get the data on your site in
a much
Timlin manners so I mentioned tensorflow
hop I want to spend a little bit of time
on the transfer flow ha piece as I
mentioned Google provides a number of
models that have been already trained
and are making this available for the
community to use and through TF up now
if you can basically call the same exact
sequential API that you want to use on
the carrots and then you can get the
same exact model that Google built for
imagenet and then you can after that you
can use the same exact model the way you
are using your local models through
through TF up the interesting pieces in
here if you are using a full-blown model
on the hub which is the tensorflow hub I
will shorten it notebook this nut is
important right now but you can actually
get the civilized model into your local
machine and then basically wrap that
safe model and then make it ready for
you to deploy to production this is
going to be somehow important on the
retraining piece that I will be talking
later and the tff itself is not as
important maybe right on the
infrastructure part but with the
transfer learning as well as kind of
dist sharing models most of the model
architectures are becoming somehow
separated you want to learn your
embeddings your representation problems
in here and then you want to build your
application specific logic at the end on
the classification piece what does that
mean is if you already have a model that
actually trained for kind of vehicle
classification let's say in here and you
want to extend that model so that you
can classify traffic science or anything
that is related to the vehicles then you
can actually get this model put the all
of the images that you want for the
other types of datasets and then you can
retrain the model you can improve the
future learning piece you can get all of
the embeddings and then if you are
separating the future learning and
classification you can kind of consider
this as two different problems after you
improve your embeddings you can build
another classifier it
traffic signs as well as the all of the
vehicles that you have right now and or
you can basically combine feature
learning and classification and then
retrain your models based on based on
your needs
the the second piece that I will be
talking about is transfer flow model
serving the I will be spending quite a
bit of on this transfer form model
serving because it is very crucial to
put this in a production setting for
kind of da Christ version of these
services it has mean four different
components this graph is a little bit
reads from right to left rather than
left to right the client is actually
making the request so I will start with
the source the source is actually the
the place where the model sits basically
the place that you store your model this
model could be you know a plot above
this could be a save model this could be
an hdf5
file this could be anything it can be
loaded into into the memory and this
source is basically implements this file
system which is a pluggable
implementation to make this model
available the loader which implements
the transfer for servable which if you
are using safe model this is already
tensorflow servable
is responsible for loading the model and
you know it's a slaughter it just loads
the model however at this point loader
doesn't actually serve the request at
that point it pass a message to the
dynamic manager that I load this model I
have the memory for this new model and I
am asking you to serve the request into
this new model and the dynamic manager
through the version policy version pose
also plugin implementation you can
implement blue/green deployment strategy
you can do implement 10% 20% 30% through
the request strategies to be able to
serve request from old model to new
model and the dynamic managers based on
the version policy is responsible for
basically elevating the new model into
the into the service and then servable
handle will just communicate and get the
predictions from the new model through
through dynamic manager and then you
will be able to deploy this model
through through this flow so this is
important and it is more advantageous
comparing to what you want to build in
your flask applications in two different
scenarios the first one is the version
policy most of the time version policy
actually needs to be implemented on the
infrastructure level we are in the
tensor flow model serving you don't need
to really do anything it will
automatically be taking care of you if
you specify your version policy
correctly
the second piece the memory resource
constraints and everything else is
handled in the loader so in the
application we actually don't need to
specify if I don't have the memory
enough what I will be doing when there
is a new model loader will basically
look at the memory usage resource usage
and then we'll decide whether it can
actually promote that new model into the
production whether there is a new
resource or there is not a resource that
will be completely isolated to the
loader if there is not resources it will
fail it will basically print out a
message if there is a resource then it
will be able to say dynamic manager
there is an expired version that I want
to deploy to production this removes a
lot of kind of headache on very common
tasks that you might otherwise invest a
significant amount of your time to be
able to to be able to implement and put
in the production for this and the the
good and other good thing is on top of
this these are all pluggable so you can
use any type of source that you want
instead of file system you can use a
different
servable if you want to and then version
policy for certain models you may want
to use a different version policy and
for other models you may want to use
completely different version policy and
I couldn't make it bigger sorry about
this my HTML skills are not great and
the continuous training pipeline fits in
this very it will give you the memory
issue I don't know if it says this is
the memory that you have this is the
memory it I require it says that it
failed due to memory resource content or
the issue is self however you may you
may make I think based on some numbers
you can also probably output those
numbers as well yeah however I saw for
the special memory it says basically I
felt due to memory resource constraints
I don't have any memory basically yep
and in here on the continuous training
pipeline what you want to do is you have
this data you want to learn on this type
of data and then you want to deploy that
model to the tensor for serving
continuously and tensorflow serving will
take everything like take care of
everything for you to be able to deploy
this model on the layer and then the
clients based on that version policy
will be able to get the predictions from
the models seamlessly this is kind of
the aspired you know continuous
deployment for the machine learning
where you want to be able to deploy
models and without disturbing anything
on the client side and from very outside
right what does this look like
you had this model file you have this
model service client asks what is in
this image and then models are would
will say it is panda with 0.89
probability very high level on how it
can work I provided a kind of transfer
no it's not that is up to you so you can
so in the end point it's off the do not
the signature but the model name will be
there so the end point itself basically
will say this is a image classifier or
this will be the model name that you
want to specify in the training piece
that piece of information will be there
in the end point itself also the one two
three will be also there so client can
move those version numbers basically I
want to get predictions on the front one
on the front two so that you can put the
deployment piece on the client rather
than server handling and or you can put
in a wrapper on top of that and then
whatever the expired version is on the
latest model you can serve the
predictions all the time from there and
then client doesn't need to know
anything it is very flexible in that
sense it will basically have the model
name and the version number and then
based on the ten point you will be able
to get any type of predictions that you
want and the links basically will give
you the hub and model serving now I will
if there is any questions I will answer
those and then I will show a number of
notebooks on how you can actually do
this from intent on the server client
you will be able to see the endpoint
there - are there any questions over
okay sure yeah yep court years let's say
what's your side already so if the
question is if there is any multiple
models on the server side how do I get
multiple predictions for models is that
correct so if that would be the case you
can create an intermediate wrapper on
top of those two models and then get the
prediction in a single time if you don't
want to do that on the client you can
ask it the first model and then you can
ask in the second model which is
probably more granular model for the k-9
and then you will be able to get a much
sub granular dog right there so the
transfer flow we've already went through
this is basically the that small kind of
continuous training pipeline and the
serving piece in here the model to model
one can be done on the client side where
you can actually get predictions from
model to model one or you can basically
say I don't want to know what the server
side models have and then I just want to
get the request and then response and
then you will be able to get it if you
want to do other things not just the
model predictions you can create a like
a very lightweight API on top of the
models and then provide the predictions
they're currently tensorflow serving
supports
multiple models however it doesn't
support any type of orchestration on top
of those two separate models so if you
want to get the predictions on different
models you need to call separately and
then the one thing I want to mention is
it also supports GRP see this is
google's remote procedure call with the
transfer full of two it also supports
completely HTTP JSON as well so
basically you have two different options
if you want to make it really performant
efficient
you can use G RPC plus protobuf or if
you want to use HTTP you can also do
HTTP JSON combination as well in the
tensorflow one the only supported G RPC
so you always needed to write a HTTP
wrapper on top of it if you want to do
HTTP communication now you don't need to
do anything you actually don't even need
to write any Python code it just
supports HTTP out of the box which I
will shove on the on the later and then
I have the first kind of REST API
example I will be going through the
docker file so the transfer flow model
server doesn't work in Mac's
they couldn't fix this even in the
transfer flow - it works in Linux very
well and today I will be going through
this docker files all the time I want to
just say quick hands how many people
have used docker containers Asian
communities before
is there anything ok
some people have used I will go a little
bit quickly the docker is basically a
containerization containerization
library or I would not say library but
containerization framework let me put it
this way it is a virtualization machine
on top of the machine that you have this
is not great definition but bear with
you specify a base machine Ubuntu 16
that you want to use that machine on
your local Mac and then based on that
Ubuntu you can basically install
anything you want and the reason why we
are trying to do this is because we want
to have a Linux machine it will
basically emulate a Linux box on on our
local machine and the important thing is
this tensor flow model server Google
makes this available on the on the UNIX
machines and then you will be able to
get all of the tensor flow model server
model serving when you register their
URL and then after that you can
basically install through up get update
and transfer model server in here the
important thing is I will show what the
secret does is but for the G RPC and
HTTP REST API we are exposing two
different ports if you are using G RPC
only you just need to expose a single
port if you want to use HTTP you want to
just expose another port and what this
fashion Emma NIST's yep so the RPC is
much more efficient than HTTP for for
communication Google has a number of
kind of comparison between HTTP and RPC
it is just much more efficient for
specifically Python and the transfer
flow context the internally they use
protobuf protobuf with the GRP see in
both model definition as well as how
they communicate between client and
server fits very nicely on how you would
be able to communicate on the GRP cps so
they basically provide a number of
interfaces for the GRP see that you can
basically hard cut on what the response
would look like and then based on that
protobuf if your client is java if your
client is Civic your client is Android
you will be able to use the same exact
protobuf definition and then we'll be
able to share it that schema between
client and server yep currently though
they I think trying to get away from G
RPC especially for community set up
because everybody was building HTTP
reports on yet we used to build HTTP
wrappers because our schedule F which we
used nomad which is a half-shell core
product didn't actually know how to
register G RPC services so we didn't
have any choice except built HTTP
services because otherwise we won't be
able to even talk across across the
network between different services yep
and the fashion minused file is nothing
but a best-equipped which basically
calls transfer to a model server and in
the docker file I hope exposed the REST
API which is what I am going to use as
well and then in here in your question
the model name fashion model is going to
be dead urls URL pad basically whatever
you want to specify there you can
basically expose it in the endpoint URL
and then will be able to call it model
URL in there and then let's see how this
actually works if we go in here I just
I'm going to build the docker file I
already built so it will be quick
hopefully
the thing that I'm trying to do is
basically this moving models as well as
the the the C crypt into the docker and
then the execution is going to happen in
here and then after that I will be able
to run this Python notebook and the
models as well as other things are
specified in here so when I run the
tensor flow model servers while the
docker is building you will specify
basically the model name in here in the
same instance of the Machine under
models you will be able to have multiple
models that will register this is very
important to decouple all of the model
deployments so you can consider you have
a same instance and you have multiple
doctor files that will deploy your
application that will let deploy your
models no matter what instance will get
which model since you have multiple
docker files with the different models
name and it will register the same exact
URL this provides a consistency across
the board without us necessarily doing
anything and the the port is also
something we can control
so as long as you share the ports and
other types of models in here you will
be able to get a very consistent
consistent endpoints for a number of
things I just get this data set from
from I think sorry there is a fashion
means a data set from my teachers and
today what I will be doing is in here I
will train a simple model I will save
this model in the state model I will
show a couple of things on what sate
model looks like and then this outputs a
lot of log lines and then in here so
after you have the model if you are
using the new
API this sake model storing is as simple
as this
this was very complicated picking the
tensorflow one days you specify the
model you specify an export path which
you are going to load the model from
there and then you will be able to save
the tensorflow model into that location
and then I will do that and then if you
want to look at what this model looks
like you can click on this there I will
be sharing this and they also provide a
state model CLI tool to actually see
what this model actually is this is also
very important if you want to look at
what type of transferee you need to pass
kind of what is the method name that is
going to call and everything else this
also has a number of things and in here
previous you need to actually specify
signature definitions on the state model
itself since we are using the Kara's
model enough in here we no longer need
to specify the signature definitions
this is automatically embedded into the
model specifications so you will be able
to reuse whatever you want to specify on
the training into the into the
predictions without necessarily
specifying anything on the on the on the
serving player this is also very
important so consider this kinda
scenario right you have ten people in
the data science that are training
different types of models as long as the
signature definitions that they are
putting into the training same across
the board you can actually do the same
exact signature under the client and
then it will just work no matter how we
are saving that model because now go
ahead
if it is using stock calluses even if
the model is very complicated you will
be able to use this if you are not using
the calluses API then you still need to
specify the signature definition in the
alt all the way basically in the have
you ever use tensor for one in the
tensorflow one you basically need to
specify input definition out the
definition you still need to do those
yeah if you are using the Karis ap you
don't need to do and you don't need to
do those anymore
yep and the fashion Minister file is if
you are familiar with this mini Stata
set it is very simple like zero one up
two digit nine this is basically trying
to emulate the data set except in a
fashion setting the images are very
similar it is you know I think I'm sorry
28 by 28 and then it has ten classes it
is dresses it has a bunch of other
things and then if we are Icarus built
now I am going to just run by exposing
to 8 1 or 1 2 here and then it will
basically shop so let me be make it a
bit bigger actually maybe just read this
piece and make this very tiny so in here
I kind of like this a bit it basically
gives a lot of lock lines to you on what
it actually is doing you have this X
model you have this our our CNN model
you have this other model actually I
think I did build the wrong model for
example this is not correct because I
was looking at the in smaller
so
this is curriculum
I did actually let me do you wanna do
this maybe I can write it down here too
I think this should go to a guitar paper
if it doesn't let me know
yep yep you can't follow I'm sorry I
think the one or two may not be - but
most of them the first theory should be
- the first made for ya
I will update by the end of today yep
and okay this is perfect and now I have
the build and
perfect so in here as I was mentioning
this is great it actually is telling us
what it is doing it basically looking at
adding fashion model fashion model
version one this is important when it
tries to update a new model on top of
here
the solvable version is also basically
such showing all of the earlier examples
that I was giving and the reading state
model from the app models one this is
basically the local that I am storing
where I am storing to modely' stuff and
it shows a number of things related to
the tensorflow binary how it is not
optimized for the tensorflow which is
not a concern for us but for production
deployments you may want to look at it
you can also provide one more files so
if you want to basically make sure that
the model is warmed up before you can
also provide warm up data files
unfortunately I don't have this example
in my notebooks today but you can also
do that and then the most important
thing is it registers for the gr PC on
the 8 500 which is what we specified on
the docker file and then on the rest API
it is 8 501 which is HTTP REST API
endpoint which we are going to use
notebook and you can now consider write
the terminal itself is going to be this
my server I build my model I am I built
my docker file
I'm not running my docker file in an
instance a double ace as your GCP
doesn't matter I now deployed my model
now I'm going to get predictions over
HTTP and then if I want to look at the
status response right this is also
another important thing if you want to
create a kind of health check heartbeat
type of mechanism on your service we
haven't written a single piece of Python
code right now right we had a single
model we wrote a single docker file and
it automatically exposes its status
sheriff for us to consume to get the
health checks as well as heartbeat to
make sure that this mod
is actually up and running if you look
at the metadata response now this is
your question where if you need to
actually specify the signature
definition on the models saving we
haven't specified anything on the
training piece because the Charis api
took care of that for us however if you
are not using the tensorflow you still
need to define the signature definition
because transfer form model serving
under the hood is going to locate its
signature definition own to see how to
get that prediction so that contract
between transfer model serving with the
external still needs to be there and in
here if you look at it is very similar
that inputs/outputs that we used to use
in terms of flow one and the method name
is also similar on the on the metadata
piece and then the JSON response you can
basically locate the prediction Europe
and the prediction Ural is nothing but
the periodic method on top of the model
itself and then and then here you can
look at predictions piece basically it
will return all of the probabilities and
then if you look at the class name which
is the critic maybe I can use actually
this this will be my day this will be my
prediction from the from the model that
I will be getting and in here basically
says the model was thinking this is that
it was an ankle boot and it was actually
ankle but on the training piece and if
you want to show this multiple you can
also similarly do this on the on the
data set this is some relatively simple
data set I think the model has like
around 90% of accuracy so it is hard to
find some of the miss classification
piece but you know it is possible so
this is the first example I kind of
short you know the if you have a if you
don't have anything how do you kind of
build a model through calluses
sequential API and then basically train
this model the second example is also
very similar except we are going to do a
little bit differently where we are
going to submit an image on top of on
top of the local let me build the docker
file as well while we are going to go
through them
I can do this I thank you so this is
somehow related except I'm not putting
some of my function on how we are going
to put these images into the into into
the notebook itself so in here
so every is still going to be terminal
server is still going to be the docker
file that I am going to build and I will
be running however I will be passing an
image and I will be encoding that image
into into a prediction request base64
encoded string and then I will be
posting that request and then we'll be
getting the predictions from there and
then I will be doing some sort of
average latency to see how fast the
model is the average latency is not
going to be anything meaningful because
it is you know local there is no network
communication there is no anything but
even for the sophisticated models that
doesn't have a lot of different layers
the performance is actually pretty good
comparing to if you load the model into
memory and not run through transfer flow
model server and then get the
predictions so you can do this based
based on the Charis API itself it is
actually taking longer time than this
while this actually needs to create a
separate port between your local machine
and then get the predictions which kind
of stresses how good the tensor flow
model server is in order to get the
predictions because you cannot get the
similar performance when you load this
model into the memory and then use the
characters function on top of the model
file this will be very similar to the
earlier example so I won't be spending a
lot of time there I will just execute
the same way that I'm still exposing to
eight eight five four one because again
and then I just use I need to kill that
word
I can't use the same port enough in here
I should be able to get the models
papers is the availability that we open
sourced in jet it has a number of little
files but you know it it is not very
complicated library if you are wondering
what it is and then if you look at this
latency this is general around 50 60
millisecond which is really good for
this type of dataset and then if you
want to get predictions so yeah I think
yeah yeah you can get the output
predictions from the server side this is
a cat actually but I think the class
system sauce is kind of cat related
except it is not really kind of like yet
family I guess this will be my second
notebook
the third notebook I want to go is this
notebook so this example I mentioned
tensorflow hub and in here I will be
using a transfer full of hot model and
then basically go through the same exact
process that we went through just to
show of case that you know we can
actually reuse some of the tensorflow
hub pieces as well and if you kind of
look at in here you basically need to
specify a tensorflow hop URL and based
on the terms of club hub URL this this
is just the data piece you will be able
to load that into the into the model and
I will show how we can do that actually
this is a module handle and then through
that you can get this piece so this is
what I was showing in the previous
slides I am just using hot Tara Slayer
because under the hood all of the I
wouldn't say all of them but some of the
models provide this type of layer
approach where you can actually get
multiple layers from another model and
then you can build on top of on top of
yet another model in here you can
basically get the module handle with the
trainable force where we are not going
to retrain in this notebook the original
model and then you put on top of another
layer and then you can build the model
or you can basically keep using the same
exact model with a different layer
structure and then build on top of that
in here basically we are getting the
original model from tensorflow hub and
then we are going to specify this on the
model itself and then we'll be going
through the same training piece to show
off and then I will be saving the model
and then showing this this will take
quite a bit of time so I won't go there
but the thing that I was mentioning
since now all of the transform hop
models also implements the saved model
when you save the model this is nothing
but again state model that you can just
deploy wherever you want this is pretty
powerful because now I pulled some other
model from another Reaper on the
tensorflow hub I now know what is the
signature definition what is everything
else and I know the model name
I know basically everything about the
model and then I saved the model into my
local machine now this model can be
reused for my own purposes basically
this is pretty powerful for
reusability purposes if you know the
layers as well as other things you will
be able to reuse some of the models in a
better environment than then what we
used to do in terms of flow one in
tensorflow one this was this wasn't this
easy this piece because the transfer hub
didn't implement this eight model is the
D F de facto civilization library so
that the transfer flow hub didn't
actually talked with the saved model
that you want to use when you are
deploying this sensor for mother serving
now it basically works very seamlessly
where you can get the mother from
tensorflow hub and then will be able to
deploy to the transfer flow model server
in no time and then I have another one
let's see if we can complete this I
think this will take quite a bit of time
I think I didn't push this to the to the
to them
get up I will I will do that by the end
of today this notebook actually shows
the transfer of data sets which is kind
of nice where if you want to kind of
look at different types of transfer flow
of functionality generally we need a
transfer of data set and on the transfer
flow of data sets library you can
basically get all of these data set very
quickly and very easily you can use this
chip TFTs lot to even create training
validation and test data sets which
basically provides this out of the box
and then on top of that the interesting
piece in here is when you have the data
set there I want to show of the transfer
let me actually start this so the one
thing I want to show in here is
the teleport load the extension I think
that was a talk they talked about
different types of extension in the
notebook with the tensorflow to now we
have an extension pencil board you can
actually load this extension into the
notebook and then we'll be able to
locate the locks within the notebook and
I will show off what this actually looks
like the other pieces are very similar
to what they've been showing so far the
model training will take quite a bit of
time but hopefully we will get there
and the after you load that extension
the locks line which is really the path
that you want out put your locks you can
use the same exact I think this is
called Jupiter magic or something like
this you will be able to use this on the
log DIF and then you will be able to see
there since you are executing this in
the notebook setting you need to find
the you need to find this on the
terminal
for the process idea on the tensor board
to kill it I don't think this is
possible unless you are using the basic
route in here and so I will just go to
the terminal to see what it actually is
doing and then after that we were well
it is completing our short couple of
other things now we have this plot model
piece where it can actually show all of
the layers this wasn't there before I
believe on the on the tensor clock - if
you are using Karis API as well as the
Karis module within the 10th floor - now
you can basically plot what does the
architecture looks like out of the box
this is again very similar to
scikit-learn scikit-learn also has a
functional to output random forests or
anything that is like very structurally
different than what you would normally
use transfer also now supports this type
of kind of output on the on the model
itself and then we earlier you know this
was already there on the Karis transfer
flock didn't support this but Karis has
this for a while and then it was it was
pretty much of it the transfer transfer
flow serving again is similar to what we
went through
let me show wish I did get this
okay this is almost deaf in the knavish
of the locks piece on the tensor word
and it to kill the previous one I think
hmm
I don't think this is it but
unfortunately this doesn't seem to be
working
maybe I need to shut this down or shed
it the same oh but this is fine and then
the last notebook I want to go through I
won't be running this this will be
taking a longer time this is also the
text piece of it that basically goes
through the text classification piece
again we are downloading and I am the
FGB data set from the transverse flow
data sets and then you can run this in
collab as well and then you can
basically build this on your own as well
this will be the text classification
piece on top of it and then I want to
show off one morph the SH valve and then
I will be completing this
if you want to create a client I will
shove a simple client this is one of the
notebooks as well the async doesn't
really work in the notebooks so I wanted
to separate out as well
and if you want to use HTTP this is
pretty standard requests code now we are
importing requests and you want to you
know output basically the response
content from whatever we are going to
get from the transfer flow model
prediction server and then basically get
the output the on the async i/o piece
you can basically write the function it
is going to be the one it is going to be
probable to be nut bottleneck you can
wrap this interesting function and then
based on this async function you will be
able to get the model output because
more often than not you may want to do
something else and especially for images
the civilization and the civilization
base64 encoding may actually take quite
a bit of time so there might be some
value to make the communication to be
asynchronous I kind of wanted to
showcase on how you can actually do this
now with the Python 3 I think 3.4 we
have now a synchronous function
executions so you can wrap the areas
where you can wait for a long time into
an async function and then execute this
in an asynchronous manner rather than
the ego execution that general Python
used to use to further optimize on some
of the communications in here if you are
not happy in some of the other pieces
where there is no you know necessarily
transfer involvement in here for example
we are waiting to download some piece of
data from a URL and this has nothing to
do with the transfer flow it is
completely based on the network and you
may want to do something else on top of
that on top of that function so there
might be somebody
some of the areas if you want to make it
as an asynchronous process this is
pretty much all I have for today
Thanks what is it basically in the
initialization and so I mentioned
warm-up data script as well when the
model comes along transfer flow of team
suggested you need to you you need to
warm up the model yeah a couple of times
it doesn't matter what it actually is
doing this is what I'm actually doing
this basically in here this is basically
the area that you are talking about in
order so now I am trying to measure
every straighten see in the first one or
two requests there might be some
behavior it may not be very consistent
with the rest of the model prediction
and transfer flow has actually great
blog post where there was this engineer
well let me explain this way they
observed a model prediction latency at
12:00 p.m. on the weekdays every day for
a long time basically you know and try
to understand why it is 12:00 p.m. PST
why there is anything and they are
looking at you know if there is an
insertable deployment if there is
anything like this and it is hurting the
pin p99 there is not much customer
impact but they are getting alert that
they are getting paged and they want to
understand tissue and they couldn't find
out the issue for a long time and then
they realized there is this engineer
that is around 12 p.m. that goes to the
basically lunch break where what he was
doing is he was getting his lunch and
then pressing a button to deploy the
model however since there is no warmup
when model is
actually going there even they are using
version policy and whatnot the first
request or first prove requests are
actually showing higher latency than the
rest and that's sorting they're
basically the p99 and this is basically
to try to accommodate that piece and
they are also suggesting a warmup data's
equipped which you can actually embed
onto the server config sort of model
configuration onto the con file that
actually basically does absolutely
nothing just gets the data passes to the
model it doesn't even look at the
prediction stuff but just to make sure
that you know there is at least a couple
of requests it went to the model before
it actually start serving it that's
exactly right
this way right exactly right so yes yes
in the transfer flow model serving you
can actually embed this so you don't
have to go through the docker layer
however if you already have talked
earlier warm up you can also do that
that's collected for each doctor right
yes so if you look at this basically in
here there is this actually I can just
close this guy before it registers and
register means different things based on
the infrastructure but also actually
highlighted wrong line I think yet this
one
so before the model actually starts you
can actually say so because the registry
and exposing the HTTP REST API is
happening in here before exposing these
models in the startup you can provide
this in the warm-up requests which is I
believe basically a request per line and
then make sure that when model starts up
you provide those warm-up requests and
then after model will get warmed up
through requests and then the exposing
that model in the docker will kick off
later this will be basically the model
based warm-up you can also do after you
do this on the docker file before
registry right now it'll expose to API
endpoints wherever it is registering
these APM points in your infrastructure
you can also make couple of requests to
the endpoint it doesn't it doesn't have
the specific version number so that
whatever the new model is going to come
up it will be also warmed up through the
docker layer the first one is basically
supported on the data model file itself
and this is not directly related to
docker this is basically have you know
it will expose the HTTP and G RPC and
points however if you are you know using
docker or two vanities you can also do
warm up from from the HTTP and G RPC
from kind of outside of the outside of
the docker container
does anyone have questions cool yeah so
the current so currently transfer flow
model serving is actually doing a good
job I am really happy about what we have
right now I think they are still trying
to improve some of the flow on the
training piece I was showing this
earlier on the training piece was this
this was here so in here there I think
still there were some work that needs to
be there for sure they are going to try
using to follow I think today there was
another talk
that was another initiative that they
have transfer for extended which makes
it more component-based various pieces
like pre-processing data input you know
putting that data into the model the
training piece of aspect of it I think
there is going to be much work that is
going to be there what I am more
interested in what it happens in here I
think we still don't have a good
solution in the industry where how do
you make sure that the model is passing
a number of smoke checks similar to what
we had you know have unit tests we have
regression test in the court as far as I
know there is no automatic or smart way
for us to be able to deploy the models
in a much safe way because all the time
we are you know doing this offline
evaluations we are doing online
evaluations we need to perform a be
testing we need to do a bunch of stuff
just to get the pro you know model into
production
I think you know there will be some work
it needs to be done there for sure like
I run basically a good CI CD platform
for machine learning not sure how that
is going to be there but I think there
is definitely in it and the other thing
is currently Google is pushing for civil
pushing for tensorflow yes probably you
know for a number of different use cases
I wish there is this you know standard
format which basically powers everything
like similar to this error off for
example it is you know columnar data
format it has a bunch of clients and
then everybody else is using I think
what they are going to do is with the
state model they are going to try this
type of approach I don't know if you
know this will be the state of art it
will be great if this would be the case
so that instead of me for example I do
Python in here
but maybe my API layer is Java and I
will still be able to use sate model
through Java or a JVM language which
currently for example tensorflow to
doesn't support on the state model so
you cannot use je knife Java native
interface where in the transfer flow one
you will be able to use that Java native
interface on the API deployment so there
needs to be some work there it is not a
stream line test they are promising
right now however I would think you know
there will be some improvements for sure
around those areas I hope the sate model
will be the final model specification
format it you know most people will
decide because there are also other
initiatives like Facebook's Microsoft's
there is this platform called on all nnx
I think this is yet another you know
exchange format
it has more support than Google however
for as far as I know there might be some
libraries that will convert refer back
and forth but I wish you know there is
like this standard format it you know in
other libraries can kind of reuse and
utilize what we will see yeah this this
also is basically trying to solve
that is correct yes if you have like an
MX net MX net which is from Amazon or PI
torch from Facebook they are specifying
a exchange format so basically you have
MX net model you have high-touch model
you have transfer model and then this
converter will take care of those
conversions but also I think they are
also trying to do maybe a standard
format where rather than you converting
one to another
you will convert to one to something and
then that something will be able to
easily interpret interpret credible than
the other libraries
yes PMML is exactly the yeah like it has
been there forever or yeah pickles yeah
exactly
cool thank you
[Applause]